you see my visions a bit of a hassle is
this the way to burn that cast soul this
video has had millions of views the
lockdown message we want took so
seriously now open to ridicule the Prime
Minister's stick him by his chief
adviser the government's public health
message undermined and those in Downing
Street weakened Parliament in recess but
scrutiny doesn't stop the PM face in a
grilling from select committee chairs
the panel's priority reflect in the
public mood how much do you think this
is undermined the moral authority of the
government with the public at a time
when public confidence in the government
is so important I I've commented on it I
think people know my my views I really
don't have proposed to add to it why
have you not invited the cabinet
secretary to conduct his own independent
inquiry in order to give you independent
advice quite frankly I'm not certain
right now that an inquiry into that
matter is a very good use of official
time we're working flat out on
coronavirus surely Prime Minister surely
no man is more important than keeping
this nation safe a lot of what was
written and said over Saturday and
Sunday was false he would seed sorry all
useless audience balance I am sorry for
the the pain as I said the anguish and
the heartbreak of so many people in this
country Prime Minister you said that a
number of the allegations that made
about Dominic Cummings were false you
were with him for six hours did you see
the evidence to prove that may guy I you
know I don't want to it's a simple
question yes did you see the evidence I
don't want to go into much more than
I've said did you see the evidence I
would say yes I did I don't saw the
evidence would you agree that it would
be a good idea for the cabinet secretary
to see that or it for it to be published
and then this problem might be off your
table mr. Johnson trying to put on the
table detail of his test and trace
scheme but kept being drugged
back to trickier ground there is a new
test and trace operation which will
change people's lives and which will
require a great deal of thought and
compliance get a cat I'm asking
specifically about your advice to
parents who have coded the reason you're
not giving people a straight answer
is because you are trying to protect on
it Cummings there is you sent all the
minute felt to save budgie things and
unclear things is because you are trying
not to incriminate Dominic Cummings and
you don't want to apologize for him the
problem is that means you are putting
your political concerns ahead of clear
public health messages you have a choice
between protecting Dominic Cummings and
putting the national interest first
which will it be Prime Minister well I
think my choice is out the choice of the
breach people I would want us all to
make a bet and that is as far as we
possibly can to lay aside a party
political point-scoring and to put the
national interest first this saga has
damaged the Prime Minister and his top
aide in the eyes of the country and the
eyes of his party over 40 Conservative
MPs are now calling for mr. Cummings to
stand down many more including some in
cabinet are saying the same thing
privately he's still hanging on in there
but at what cost this health and
economic crisis is nowhere near over and
the PM needs the country behind him but
faith in him and his government
undermined he's going to have to fight
as hard as he did for mr. Cummings to
win it back Beth Rigby Sky News
Westminster